good morning john there's a little
section of sidewalk that i walk down
pretty frequently and i think that what
happens is there's a convenience store
nearby people pick up like a bag of
chips or a drink and then when they're
walking home sometimes they drop the
thing on the ground after they're done
with it i do not like this it makes me
upset it makes me feel like i'm like
surrounded by people who do not respect
the space that we share and that is
irrational it takes one person walking
back and forth to the store every day
and dropping a piece of trash on the
ground for there to be 30 pieces of
trash after a month that's a lot of
trash it changes the way that it looks
but it also might be one person of the
hundreds of people who go to that
convenience store every day so like
almost no one litters but the street is
covered with trash and here's the way of
thinking about this that really changed
my mind it only takes one person every
day picking up two pieces of trash for
there to be no trash after two weeks one
of the best tools i have ever been
taught for how to understand our world
is that we often like our minds imagine
the world as like set quantities but
actually set quantities are made up of
inputs and outputs a street with no
glitter is not a street that never gets
littered on it's a street where the rate
of people dropping trash is lower than
the rate of people picking up trash it's
a flow in and out litter goes down
litter goes and the person who dropped
the trash is only half of the reason
that the trash is there the other half
of the reason is that i didn't pick it
up i'm not like equally morally
responsible for the trash on the ground
but i don't really care about morality
here i care about the trash that's on
the ground removing responsibility and
ethics from the conversation the trash
wouldn't be there if somebody had picked
it up right and so i do pick it up i
pick it up like every time and catherine
is like oh my god where where are you
going now just across the street to get
that half empty malt liquor bottle i'm
not doing this because i think that
leaving litter on the ground is like
equally morally problematic to dropping
the litter in the first place but i
think that we can all sort of vaguely
agree that like dropping some trash on
the ground is an amount some amount of
disrespectful to the space and if that's
the case then picking it back up and not
having to be there anymore is like an
equal and opposite amount of respectful
now litter on the street in my
neighborhood is not something that i'm
actually that concerned about like not
one of the world's biggest problems and
pretty much every problem that isn't a
bag of doritos in your neighbor's hedge
is more difficult to solve than like
bending over and bending back up but i
find this a useful model when thinking
about problems generally because it
tells me three things first one person
can drop a lot of trash just because
there's a lot of trash doesn't mean that
all people are dropping trash second bad
things are not static they are a result
of inflows and outflows and we cannot
stop all bad things from happening but
we can focus on decreasing the rate of
problem formation and on increasing the
rate of problem solving and finally it
is almost always easier to get mad about
something than to do something about it
even if the doing of the something is
very small and that is an instinct in me
that i need to fight against john i'll
see you on tuesday
i just finished editing this video and
discovered that there's a full minute of
time that i have which never happens to
me but since i have extra time i would
like to encourage you to go to
youtube.com scishowtangents to watch uh
the video version of scishow tangents
that we are now doing if you want to
subscribe there that would be wonderful
tangents is like a comedy game show
science podcast that i do with a couple
of people uh sari riley and sam schultz
where we try to like surprise each other
with science facts it's a very good time
you can listen to it as a podcast
wherever you get podcasts but also now
as of this week we're starting to upload
it onto youtube since i had extra time i
figured i'd let you know about a thing
that i'm excited about john again i will
see you on tuesday